The Joe Rogan Experience having to
explain to yomi park the joke
bro let me just tell everybody let me
tell everybody when Andrew and I like I
will text him occasionally uh you own me
please I apologize you're a lovely woman
I really enjoyed talking to you this is
not disrespectful not disrespectful at
all but I would text him photos of yomi
Park and then a photo of a weightlifter
the heavies
so yomi's coming on the podcast I know
but I had to have a combo with her
before I had to to tell her about the
Heavies right I didn't explain it right
the first time she was on my podcast I
was talking to Andrew about it because
he was like yo she got the heavy
so what I said what I said was we're
talking about a woman who survived who
is through five North Korea she's
escaped North Korea when she was 13. she
tells this horrific story horrific story
of her journey to get to get to America
and then she'll just like yo she got the
heavy I said on the Pod as a joke I go
bro I go I go I go I go bro I was about
to start feeding my wife rats right like
like right
so
yomi's coming on the Pod right and I go
I go no I can't let her come in the pot
without knowing a joke I feel bad like I
want her to be inside right so I called
her
and there's a phone combo of me trying
to explain to you and me what the the
the heaviest means so I go oh my God hey
like I'm so grateful that you're coming
on I just want you to know something's
your inside on the joke here I don't
want anything to be making fun of you I
just want you to be inside
and um but like the head have you seen
like people putting like the weight lift
Emoji underneath your Instagram
and she goes so sweet she goes she goes
yeah I thought that um they thought I
was getting fat
she thought that they were saying that
she was fat the whole time what and
she's coming from this country where
they're not feeding her at all and
finally she's in a place where she can
eat food and she's getting [__] fat
[__] oh my goodness
imagine being her and think you met her
she's so frail she's tiny bro she's so
tiny imagine things
imagine thinking that she's fat bro so I
go no no no it's not that we uh and I'm
stuttering I'm like the most
uncomfortable
is it on video I'll show you and uh and
it's uh I go uh I just um well you know
how you're you have
um kind of like sneaky fat tits
I'll show you look at that that's crazy
yeah that's that's crazy incredible
that's crazy the amazing lady
um listen so oh so I go I go but we were
just you know talking about that have we
call those the Heavies and it's just
like a funny inside joke and she goes
that's great that's awesome that's so
funny that's so funny blah blah she
thinks it's hilarious and um and then
comes in the pot and we joke around it
and when we were joking around with her
she said an interesting thing she goes
wow
um I've never had anybody make fun of me
to my face and then she goes freedom is
amazing
whoa and it was a cool thing like with
she was with her story nobody makes fun
of her nobody sees it of course making
fun of her story we're just boys and
balls and teasing but she had never like
had that happen at least on camera and
even that teasing is about an attractive
uh attribute we we were so we wanted to
make sure she was I mean we literally
have the the weight
there's a picture there's a picture
oh my God that's so ridiculous her hold
against that thing that says a thousand
pounds
but that's is this dude
this is this is culture now bro do we
see people post randomly that have no
clue we've spoken about it just randomly
call big moves the Heavies they have no
clue that this happened here did you
invent that term the heavy I don't know
he just I just called the Heavies but
that was that like the first time you
said it when you saw it probably when I
said it to you yeah
yeah yeah bro that's all I call them now
I mean that's all I call them people
call it that's culture man dude that's
culture